mais non seulement il a évidemment surfé
sur votre audience pour faire passer son
message mais il a fait pire que ça c'est
à dire qu'il fait partie de ces gens qui
cite Hanouna à longueur de temps pour
exister on a vu qu'il n'y a plus un
article une actualité un fait divers un
procès même sans que votre nom soit
associé à un justement à ces actualités
pour les faire relayer et ça c'est
particulièrement dégueulasse mais autre
chose de dégueulasse je veux dire qu'il
est particulièrement lâche quand on
s'appelle louboyard et qu'on vient fort
de son écharpe de député sur le plateau
d'attaquer des gens qui ne sont ni
présent ni représentés ça n'a rien de
courageux que de lancer des calomnies et
des propos diffamatoires par ailleurs
quand on est député comme il l'est on
est le garant de la loi or il devrait
savoir qu'il y a des limites légales à
la liberté d'expression qu'il revendique
liberté d'expression dont je note
d'ailleurs que vous n'en bénéficiez vous
évidemment pas en tant qu'animateur mais
la sienne doit être absolue et sans
contrainte je note enfin et ça me
dérange le plus que il a commencé sa
conférence de presse
rien de personnel or lorsqu'il vous
accuse de racisme ça vient une attaque
personnelle directe qu'il préfère à
votre rencontre et donc non seulement
c'est prémédité mais je crois que son
propos il est largement condamnable
Franck je pense que évidemment c'était
très méditer mais je pense qu'il était
le seul à la France insoumise à savoir
coller de son petit piège je pense que
c'était absolument pas du tout organisé
avec les autres il a joué sa partition
ce qui montre déjà que il est peut-être
député France insoumise ou Nuxe il faut
choisir mais il joue vraiment son propre
avenir et sa propre partition il y avait
pas de complice je pense que pour faire
un clash pareil ils ont une trahison
pareille faut être tout seul
premièrement deuxièmement c'est pas la
faire luboyard c'est la faire les
insultes finalement parce que les
insultes et vous vous êtes excusé vous
avez vu raison vous excusez de cela mais
si on met oui je sais que c'est
compliqué c'est difficile après ça
excusez hein
vous regretter les insultes mais c'est
bien de les avoir regretté parce que je
pense que si on enlève les insultes de
cette séquence le piège de Fort-Boyard
comme on le dit le piège se retourne
contre lui parce que venir bien sûr
essayez de de court-circuiter une
mission comme ça qui a toujours donné la
parole aux insoumis depuis le début
c'est vraiment du et quand on a 22 ans
se suicider politiquement comme ça faut
être complètement dingue donc
malheureusement il y a eu ce petit
passage avec les mots malheureux que
vous avez regretté mais sinon tout le
reste évidemment cet après-midi tout
seul c'est surtout pas alors encore une
carrière normalement c'est vrai
exactement on va voir la succession
parce que
plus là donc il doit penser à lui
Mélenchon
et le niveau de Liberia excusez-moi
c'est comme si tu dis je sais pas moi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est Federer
alors en 2019 lorsque pour la première
fois une personnalité politique partie
si vraiment à l'une de mes émissions
c'est Marlène Schiappa qui avait accepté
de co-animer un numéro spécial de BTP
regardez ce qu'ils m'ont dit puisque là
aussi j'étais encore macroniste regardez
merci d'être là alors je vous ai mis un
tabouret un paperboard et votre ami
voilà
merci d'être là en tout cas des
courageux de votre part de devenir vous
voulez vous asseoir peut-être ça va
jusqu'ici on voulait absolument que vous
soyez là ce soir c'est vrai aussi parce
que vous êtes vous êtes vous allez être
un petit peu notre notre messager on va
dire voilà parce que nous voilà nous on
est on est on est on s'y connaît on a
peut-être des idées mais il faudrait
nous éclairer sur des choses voilà on
connaît pas
alors donc là les tweets pareil c'est
gênant la carrément vous donner la
chaîne à Macron pour faire sa propagande
à vomir on voit que Hanouna et promo
Macron voilà donc c'était partout elle
avait d'ailleurs dû se justifier dans
les médias Marlène Schiappa après vous
allez voir avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Mathieu voulait dire quelque chose avant
d'oublier parce que juste un mot sur le
sur le racisme parce que moi c'est ce
qui m'a beaucoup touché parce que en
vous accusant il nous accusé aussi et
c'est vrai que ce weekend il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui m'ont envoyé
des textos qui m'ont appelé pour me
rappeler que en tout cas si il trouve
une autre émission ou autour de la table
tous les soirs il y a
maghrébin je sais pas blanc noir
musulman juif pardon gay lesbien enfin
toutes les minorités possibles à la fois
tous les soirs sont là pour débattre de
tout pardon si on trouve une autre
émission où il y a ça tous les soirs en
direct comme comme et surtout le public
de l'émission le public de l'émission
voilà et donc après ça je vais vous dire
et je vous en parlerai tout à l'heure
pour moi en disant ça il s'est
disqualifié
moi ça me touche pas du tout parce que
les choses me touchent quand on veut de
la variante voilà quand on me dit des
choses vraies voilà mais là pour le coup
vraiment je vous dis pour moi
complètement là dessus voilà là-dessus
des disqualifié on va revenir sur son
tweet et je vais revenir ce que je vous
donne toutes les clés tout à l'heure
pour moi ça c'était voilà oui c'était
quelque chose de positif aussi qu'il
faut sortir de cela c'est celui qui a
une énorme attente en fait finalement
cette émission de la part des politiques
et de la part des Français et je pense
que c'en est rendu compte à ce moment-là
vous avez plus parler c'est vrai
l'animateur vous aviez avant qu'au
débuter mais ça montre aussi à quel
point comme toute la classe politique
réagit de façon outrancière aussi les
insultes hein faut le savoir ils sont
devenus tous fous c'est hystérique ça
monte à quel point finalement cette
émission a pris de la valeur et de
l'importance chez eux donc ça monte
quelque part que si j'étais une petite
émission de rien du tout c'était pas
important si c'était uniquement du
divertissement on s'appelle là ça montre
que c'est presque un appel je le dis en
off en disant Cyril attention on compte
sur toi il faut remettre du niveau parce
que nous on veut venir encore chez toi
donc quelque part l'affaire de
va peut-être vous donner je pense je
vous le souhaite à tous ça rebond en se
disant bah on va mettre la barre plus
haute peut-être ok on va il y aura pas
d'insultes il y aura pas de tout le
monde pourra le dire tout dire comme
toujours depuis le début tout le monde
aura la parole mais on va peut-être
élever le débat encore plus fort pour
essayer de plaire à une audience plus là
finalement donc moi je pense que c'est
peut-être un signe parce que si vous
étiez pas important pour les politiques
il y aurait jamais eu de monter au
créneau comme ça alors ensuite c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce qui va se
passer l'audience de TPMP va monter
plutôt que descendre bien sûr que tu as
quand même des élus qui osent conseiller
au peuple de boycotter TPMP qui est un
petit hémicycle aussi comme l'Assemblée
nationale comme le comme le Sénat sauf
que nous on est devant 2 millions de
personnes et si eux ils comptent
demander au peuple de renoncer à cet
espace de liberté qui est tellement rare
c'est quand même très gonflé de leur
part je pense que notre audience va
monter que davantage ah bah ça va encore
plus ces énervé alors ensuite j'ai reçu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'embtp ou dans face
à Baba et c'est vrai que Jean-Luc voilà
je l'ai reçu plusieurs fois c'est
l'homme politique le important
aujourd'hui voilà candidat au
présidentiel parce que chez le plus reçu
voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon bien plus Éric
Zemmour s'il y en a qui pensent que
j'irai plus reçu effectivement non celui
qui est le plus reçu c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors après et bien c'est bien
dommage de n'avoir que des gauchistes
pour ce genre d'émission débat de
société
l'extrême gauche présente Hanouna
devrait renommer balance ton poste qu'à
gauche en sortant dans TPMP c'est que
des comptes gaucho balance ton poste
émission pour diffuser la parole de la
France insoumise euh voilà Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
pas exprimé vous allez me dire pourquoi
à votre avis moi il y a un truc que je
voudrais vous montrer avant qu'on parle
de l'absence de réaction et je le
comprends de Raquel Garrido avec ses
Corbières et Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
allez me dire pourquoi votre avis nous
paraît si en janvier 2017 on m'avait
accusé
d'être gauchiste et même de banaliser
l'islamisation parce que j'avais reçu
une femme voilée qui avait gagné un jeu
dans le public regardez
c'est jaune 13 c'est fou que j'ai tiré
le 13 le numéro 13
c'est le 13 le jaune 13 est-ce qu'il y a
un jaune de 13 oui
merci d'être là merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes alors je vérifie vous êtes
bien le 13 jaune c'est magnifique ce que
je peux vous faire un bisou merci d'être
là merci vous avez un sourire magnifique
merci je vous le dis vraiment
elles sont très très bon en plus oui ça
me change des chroniqueurs elle a été
très très fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la montre connectée ma chérie qui est là
c'est pas un énorme bisou merci d'avoir
été la voiture merci tu as un amour tu
es contente et ben nous aussi et là donc
on m'avait dit voilà je vous dis c'était
incroyable les tentatives de la
banalisation du voile dans l'espace
public passe par les médias non mais
c'est incroyable voilà pas que ça voilà
il y en a eu d'autres hein voilà je vous
le dis voilà donc c'est vrai que et
après je vous le dirai après quand j'ai
reçu Eric Zemmour quand j'ai reçu Marine
Le Pen à pas là voilà Hanouna aura fait
plus on aura plus fait pour la fragrand
des idées d'extrême droite que la mafia
Le Pen en 50 ans
rappelle à ceux qui ont des problèmes
d'histoire que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
au deuxième tour en 2002 ce n'est pas
encore télé voilà merci donc c'est vrai
que stagiaire je pouvais pas faire
beaucoup donc voilà donc pour vous dire
les conneries que j'ai vu passer
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de tout ça
qu'à chaque fois on me dit voilà je suis
à droite je suis à gauche au milieu
voilà on m'a reproché d'avoir des des
femmes voilées dans le public donc j'ai
dit pour les faire encore plus chier
bientôt je vais je voulais en mettre une
chroniqueuse d'ailleurs on a fait des
tests on va voir ça va arriver
certainement alors si vous dites bien
globalement dans le paysage audiel
français une sorte d'intolérance à
l'égard de ce qu'est la France vous êtes
vous le reflet de la France dans sa
diversité il y a dans le discours
audiovisuel prégnant
prédominant une uniformité qui ne plaît
plus d'ailleurs aux Français on voit que
les audiences sont globalement très
mauvaises sur les chaînes concurrentes
et donc c'est le reflet du fait qu'il y
a chez vous quelque chose qu'il ne
trouve pas ailleurs et ça c'est
évidemment gênant pour ceux qui ne
veulent pas entendre quelque chose
différent de ce qu'ils sont pourtant
c'est une réalité vous avez raison de
continuer à la valoriser ce qui fait
votre succès et la meilleure récompense
de cela c'est évidemment le public qui
vous suit et qui vous est fidèle on dit
que je suis rivé sur les audiences mais
les audiences pourquoi c'est comme quand
à l'école tu travailles un contrôle
si tu as travaillé comme un fou et tu es
un deux tu vas dire bon bah écoute je
suis dégoûté non mais c'est vrai et je
voudrais dire et on m'a on m'a reproché
aussi d'avoir été sympa avec Jordan
Bardella la semaine dernière mais Jordan
Bardella il m'a pas insulté quand il est
venu Jordan Bardella il a été tout souri
il a été très sympathique on a pu
discuter avec lui voilà et parfois on
n'est pas d'accord avec Jordan Bardella
ou Julien Oudoul qui va venir nous
rejoindre dans un instant et ça se passe
on discute et même Julien ou double je
lui dépasse d'armes avec lui très
chaudes voilà mais il est revenu et ça
s'est passé mais donc voilà donc alors
je vais demander l'avenir dans
l'émission je veux dire alors ça va je
vais il est pas venu avec les mêmes
dispositions que Louis Boyard mais c'est
une très bonne nouvelle finalement
toutes ces accusations parce que chaque
camp vous accuse de faire monter l'autre
on vous accuse que de faire monter
monter monter les idées politiques
finalement mais est-ce que c'est pas le
but de cette émission et de ce que vous
avez fait avec face à Baba vous faire
monter l'idée de la politique auprès des
Français les politiques sont les
premiers aspects en me disant que la
parole publique et politique n'intéresse
plus personne et quand une émission fait
monter de façon forte ces idées là on
lui reproche donc continuer à faire ce
que vous faites qui continuent à vous
reprocher tout ça et vous allez voir que
vous aurions vous remonter
Eric une question très simple est-ce que
autour de cette table animateur ou
chroniqueur quelqu'un a déjà reçu des
consignes de ce comporter de telle ou
telle façon selon l'invité jamais qu'il
soit de droite d'extrême droite de
gauche d'extrême gauche donc tout ça et
du pipeau voilà et ça se saurait
Eric qui était là avec moi dans BTP on
se rappelle qu'on préparait les
émissions politiques d'emballage je peux
vous dire qu'il y avait pas de consigne
eric est à penser de la séquence toi je
t'ai vu extrêmement énervé ça s'est
passé en deux temps il y a eu un temps
très attendu puis un temps très
inattendu le temps attendu c'est qu'en
général la France insoumise ne vient pas
pour débattre du sujet en discussion il
vient pour faire de la propagande
d'ailleurs viens faire du hors sujet
pour faire passer des messages ils s'en
foutent de ce que tu racontes le sujet
c'est ça c'est pas grave on va te parler
d'autre chose ça c'est le côté attendu
le côté inattendu c'est qu'en effet
après tu as été traité de type d'extrême
droite de de racisme je pense en
fouillant un peu dans les mails on doit
dans les dans les tweets on doit trouver
fasciste et même nazis en chaque fois un
petit peu et c'est quand même étrange
parce que tu as rappelé notre commune
participation à à balance ton poste il y
a aucune autre émission au monde qui a
reçu par exemple plus de gilets jaunes à
la fois comme chroniqueur ou dans le
public parfois il y avait plusieurs
dizaines de gilets jaunes il y en avait
plusieurs autour de la table personne
n'a eu Raquel Garrido Jérôme Rodriguez
comme voilà comme comme
chroniqueur donc tout ça est d'une
malhonnêteté incroyable et je dirais
même que la lâcheté est à deux niveaux
parce que l'état-major de France
insoumise n'ose pas n'ose pas aller
contre Louis Boyard il se contente
d'être silencieux Mélenchon ne dit rien
car il ne dit rien Corbière de dis rien
ils très bien qu'il a déconné savent
très bien qu'il s'est comporté de
manière incroyable peut-être aussi que
Garrido et Corbières se souviennent
qu'ils sont son prix physiquement à
Stanislas Rigo après un balance ton
poste et autre chose que des que des moi
je le prends pas comme ça moi Eric je te
le dis moi je suis plus joyeux moi je
pense que c'est la loyauté aussi de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dit voilà Cyril
il est comme moi aussi il est sanguin
moi aussi j'ai plus de sanguin et je
suis comme Cyril et que je l'ai invité
plein de fois Jean-Luc raquette je veux
bien c'est la nuit
d'analyser leur silence si c'était
exprimé les choses serait claires là on
est en train de gloser de spéculer sur
leur silence j'en sais rien est-ce que
c'est pas un peu de la honte de leur
petit protégé qui soit comporter de
manière moi je le prends comme ça je le
prends comme comme une preuve d'amitié
voilà je vous le dis comme Alexis je
m'entends très bien avec lui je l'ai
jamais caché ici Alexis Corbières on
s'entend très bien Raquel élection s'en
rappelle Eric on va pas on dit les
choses ici on était en loge on faisait
des rigolades ensemble on a rigolé
pendant des des des semaines et des
semaines quand on fait BTP
sont des amis je veux dire à quel c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai très souvent au
téléphone par SMS dès qu'il y a un
problème on se le dit je vous le dis que
lorsqu'il y a eu les élections
présidentielles raquettes j'ai eu quatre
fois dans la journée au téléphone voilà
c'est quelqu'un voilà avec qui je
m'entends très très bien Alexis aussi et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je m'en suis jamais
caché que on s'aimait bien tous les deux
voilà on a plus on a pu avoir des on
sait je vous le dis il y a un jour je le
raconte un dimanche après midi Jean-Luc
et moi on s'est appelé il devait faire
l'émission le Mardi Jeudi écoute tu es
on s'est dit tu es devenu habitues tu me
fais chier et ben moi aussi bah tu me
fais chier bah si c'est comme ça il y a
pas d'émission bon on sait on s'est
raccroché au nez on s'est rappelé après
et après voilà on sait on est comme ça
mais mais Jean-Luc il est voilà il est
sanguin aussi mais ça n'empêche pas que
et c'est vrai moi je vais vous dire j'ai
de la peine pour pour la France
insoumise et pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce que c'est le chef il n'y a rien de
du parti et aujourd'hui ils vont être
dans un truc ou qu'est-ce qu'on fait
Siri il a toujours été
ce jour essayer de l'inviter donc
les objets juste que je disais tout à
l'heure je suis absolument convaincu on
le verra que ni Jean-Luc Mélenchon
nigerido nicorbières ne savait de préau
de loin ce que préparer Boyard il a fait
un piège il a fait son petit truc perso
ce qui pense à son CV il a 22 ans il se
dit moi l'avenir est devant moi bon le
mur aussi c'est que il a encore une fois
court-circuiter et pour moi c'est
l'émission qui faisait la part belle
comme vous l'avez dit la France
insoumise pendant longtemps et c'est un
suicide politique pour moi parce qu'ils
ont qui sont gênés ils savent pas
comment faire ils peuvent pas critiquer
leur députés en même temps ils disent
mais quelle connerie que tu as fait tu
les as coupé le plus grand canal de
d'information vis-à-vis des gens et de
communication avec le grand public
Florence Nicky rinolo et et Franck
Tapiro et les autres les chroniqueurs
aussi quand on voit la réaction de de
certains journalistes voilà c'est ça
Géraldine ah ouais on se dit on a
l'impression qu'ils vivent pas dans le
même monde que nous comment ça se fait
ça moi ce weekend en fait j'ai beaucoup
regardé alors c'est pas les hommes
politiques j'ai regardé si j'ai regardé
les les éditorialistes journalistes les
commentateurs en fait c'est ça et en
fait moi ça m'a un peu écœuré parce
qu'en fait on a consulter on a été
insulté comme si finalement TPMP était
une sous-émission si on était regardé
par les sous citoyen ils sont très
jaloux ils sont très très jaloux
fait 300000 sur 2 millions parce que les
gens qui nous regardent vote comme ceux
qui regardent BFM comme ceux qui
regardent ces news des premiers de la
classe je te dis bah oui bah comme ça
qu'on fait avancer il a démocratie ni le
débat et on a le droit nous de recevoir
des politiques d'en parler à notre
manière de parler du pouvoir d'achat
avec des politiques qui s'adressent à
des gens qui ne regardent pas BFM ou qui
ne regardent pas cnews ou qui ne
regardent pas LCI je te comprends tout à
fait ma chérie je suis complètement
d'accord avec toi tous les gens ici là
non vous vous êtes pas vraiment vous
êtes un peu en dessous quoi
c'est le seul c'est la seule prise
qu'ils ont parce qu'il se disent en vrai
on a quand Gérald Darmanin fait face à
Baba il a pas la même intensité et ses
équipes n'ont pas la même pression que
quand ils font BFM je suis désolé ou LCI
on va pas se mentir c'est vrai ou pas
c'est un événement pour lui d'être face
à Baba en direct et ça ne croyez pas ça
les énerve
dans un monde idéal les articles se
réécrits sur la base de ce qu'ils ont vu
dans l'émission ce qu'ils prennent le
parti de bruyère non l'article est écrit
avant toute façon exactement il faut se
farcir à Nouna donc de toute façon tu
sais ça veut dire ce que tu voulais
l'insulter un peu plus l'insulter un peu
moins dire autre chose dire une autre
fois l'article est écrit
ils auraient pris parti
c'est que c'est que vous n'êtes pas du
Sarah entre guillemets pendant 40 ans
c'était les journalistes qui
interviennent les politiques point barre
et là tout d'un coup pardon mais vous
n'êtes pas journaliste vous animateurs
c'est un animateur qui est interdit les
hommes politiques vous l'avez fait à
l'époque de face à Baba c'était au
niveau au moment des élections pour
intéresser les jeunes à la politique
parce que j'étais en train de fuir et du
coup forcément vous êtes sympathique
avec tout ce que soit Mélenchon moi j'ai
entendu tout était Sarkozy macroniste
mais l'anxioniste et même moi je ne sais
pas pour qui vous votez mais j'ai tout
entendu mais évidemment vous êtes
sympathique quand vous les recevez vous
êtes animateur et vous mettez des gens
en face qui eux vont se prendre la tête
avec le médecin pareil dans les
coulisses
comme ça
de venir ici et d'être face à quelqu'un
mais évidemment mais
les journalistes ils nagent dans une
piscine de Somme parce que contrairement
aux arrivées à créer l'événement qu'on
va recevez les politiques et moi j'en ai
marre qu'on pose cette question de la
légitimité de Cyril Hanouna à recevoir
les politiques ou non il y a un moment
si vous étiez bon qu'à faire des retours
de perruques face à Baba sur un flop la
dernière partie de l'émission sur un
flop manque de bol pour eux ça fait 2
millions de téléspectateurs et ce qu'il
faut se poser c'est la question inverse
est-ce que c'est pas eux la plupart des
journalistes qui sont tous fade et
insipide qui servent à rien puisqu'ils
ne ressent rien de leurs émissions
l'avenir pour moi des émissions
politiques on l'a fait quand même depuis
pas mal de temps c'est face aux citoyens
justement bien sûr j'aimerais bien que
fasse ce journaliste personne ne regarde
aussi bon soit-il c'est pas la qualité
des journalistes s'efface citoyen en
2007 on avait fait j'ai une question à
vous poser ou c'était tous les candidats
de la République face à une assemblée de
sans citoyens représenter de gauche
extrême droite sans que la politique ça
a été un carton elle a fait le tour du
monde on a fait près de 9 millions dès
la première pourquoi parce que c'était
les citoyens qui étaient face à un homme
politique qui était en passe de devenir
président un public et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous faites ici
c'est un peu cela on a besoin de la
reine citoyenne c'est ça qui va
réintéresser pour revenir là-dessus
parce que moi je voudrais saluer et je
le dis en tout cas pour l'instant la
loyauté de Raquel Garrido Alexis
Corbières et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils se
disent c'est un gars de chez nous face à
un mec qui est plutôt notre pote donc
comment on fait on est un peu dans la
merde c'est comme voilà c'est comme ça
que ton père et ta mère
a dit des choses extrêmement graves oui
c'est vrai ça donc ça peut pas garder
une position
on peut dire ce qu'a dit ils peuvent
dire Mélenchon Garrido Corbières peuvent
dire les propos tenus par Boyard étaient
aussi inacceptables il est faux d'après
notre expérience que Hanouna promeut le
racisme les idées d'extrême il y avait
un service minimum à faire cette
neutralité est une forme de la moto
soutenir quelque part je suis pas
d'accord avec Eric parce que leur
silence c'est quand même lourd de sens
leur silence ça vaut désapprobation pour
louer Boyard pour moi
gêné exactement et moi je voulais dire
aussi moi je pense je trouve que c'est
voilà c'est c'est faire c'est
franchement c'est fair-play après voilà
ce que je voulais dire aussi par rapport
aux journalistes c'est que moi quand
même j'ai été choqué ce week-end par des
questions de journalistes qui ont
totalement éditorialisé BFM TV
par Benjamin
alors Benjamin biomel je vais vous le
dire c'était en plus c'est moi qui ai
mis le pire étrier c'est le fils de
Patrice Duhamel qui était patron de
France Télévisions il m'a demandé de
prendre son fils en stage à l'époque je
l'ai mis dans le groupe etc après c'est
Marc-Olivier Fogiel qui l'a pris à BFM
puisqu'il connaît très bien son père
voilà qu'il a fait travailler également
à France Télévisions voilà donc lui lui
aussi c'est encore un gars qui crache
dans la soupe et il y en a un autre donc
je parlerai demain c'est Bertrand
Chameroy qui a fait une chronique qui a
dit il faut que l'arcom arrête voilà se
saisissent de la faire et et rapidement
et vraiment réveillez-vous l'arcom il
faut arrêter il faut arrêter que ça se
passe ça dans TPMP
qui flippait dans les couloirs avant de
venir dans l'émission qui nous a planté
des milliers de fois et encore je
pourrais raconter d'autres choses sur
lui mais voilà mais je le raconterai
s'il continue voilà
Bertrand Chameroy qui fait bien le malin
et quand il voit il se chie dessus
c'est un peu comme tout le monde c'est
ça le problème voilà merci en tout cas
Franck et Flo vous avez un truc à
rajouter oui peut-être un point parce
que vous avez évoqué tous ceux qui
appellent l'arcom à se positionner sur
ce sujet et moi j'ai un problème avec
tous ces gens qui disent comme Louis
Boyard l'a dit lors de sa conférence de
presse que tout cela est une affaire
exactement il a profité cette relation
d'amitié donc d'ouverture
ancienne amitié et la visibilité et la
visibilité exactement